pretty much wherever you're going in
beirut at the moment
it's the same scenes of destruction and
devastation
yeah a huge amount of destruction still
for them all to cope with i mean
the whole of this street this goes on
for streets and streets they are
counting the cost of what this explosion
means to their businesses and
i mean just one shop owner told me just
to replace the front of his shop that's
going to cost him 50
000 and uh the
work construction company wanted 25 000
in cash which obviously they just don't
have access to
right now whole along of this street
there are
businesses which are going to be
crippled by this businesses who
are finding it very difficult anyway and
because of this there is a lot of anger
there is a lot of frustration
there's a lot of um demands for action
and of course the international
community
is stepping in we're going to see the
french president emmanuel macron
is meant to be here today he's going to
be presumably coming with some
form of um action plan to try and help
lebanon because
they are really suffering one of the
doctors will look at the amount of
destruction here one of the doctors that
we were speaking to yesterday at
one of beirut's busiest and
biggest hospitals were saying that he
really expected a coronavirus spike
at the end of this because they simply
had no
way of adhering to the social distancing
rules let's cross over the street
because there's another
very badly affected area across let's
try and see if we can get over
um he was expecting another covert 19
spike and of course this is a country
that can bear has got a creaking medical
infrastructure
as it is so and and right now all of the
hospitals are full
and still as we were seeing still
injuries are arriving they might not
have
or they might have had immediate
attention and they still need
a lot of help just to mention that one
four day old baby that we
featured um overnight who's in
critically ill
in intensive care has shown signs of
improvement she was
very badly hurt and got brain injuries
after
the explosion happened and she and her
mother were showered with glass while
she was breastfeeding
she appears to have made some progress
overnight she's taken in
10 milliliters of milk and
they are still considering whether to
carry out brain surgery on her
but certainly this morning the parents
were
slightly relieved and a little bit more
optimistic about
her future